hey 42 here when were you born
what have I told you that the month in
which you were born determines how lucky
you will be throughout your life being
born for example in June instead of
September could be the difference
between being successful in your job
being wealthy being happy and having a
good relationship this is not some
astrological mumbo-jumbo horoscope no
those things are about as useful as a
soggy flan I'm talking about scientific
studies based on empirical evidence that
have revealed what for a long time the
scientific community thought has no
basis in fact that's when someone is
born changes every aspect of their life
British psychologist Richard Wiseman and
author of the brilliant book quirkology
conducted an online study of over 40,000
people he collected their birth date and
asked them whether they consider
themselves to be lucky or unlucky the
study revealed a significant divide
between the look of those born in the
summer from those born in the winter the
results showed that people who were born
in the summer between March to August
were considerably luckier in life the
noes born in the winter between
September to February how can this be is
there some kind of supernatural
phenomenon that changes every single
life event based on when somebody was
born or perhaps astrology has some merit
well it's either that or there's
something entirely more rational and
less utterly quacky [ __ ] going on
here wise man postulated that perhaps
the stark difference in weather
conditions at birth between the summer
and winter could have a long-term effect
on a person's look as bonkers as this
sounds he decided to verify the results
by conducting a duplicate of the
experiment in the southern hemisphere
Wiseman once again conducted an online
poll but this time with the general
public of New Zealand the logic here
being at the seasons are
first in the southern hemisphere
opposite to Britain in New Zealand June
July and August are the coldest months
and December January and February are
the hottest and so if look is somehow
linked to temperature then the results
should be reversed in New Zealand and
yes they were people in New Zealand let
look here lives when they were bored in
the warmer months between September to
February and were less lucky when born
in the cold mum's between March and
August you may be wondering how does one
define look after all it's not exactly
something that can be measured or by all
rational thoughts even exists look is by
popular scientific consensus and by my
estimation the false attribution of
positive or negative outcomes to
supernatural or religious forces instead
of random chance or just human endeavor
at the end of the day look is
essentially a descriptor that we place
upon ourselves in the form of either
good or bad look based on our personal
experiences but during this study wise
we found that people who describe
themselves as lucky do in fact have more
good look and vice-versa
he tells of the example of one female
participant Susan from Blackpool who
describes herself as unlucky and boy was
she and no not just because she lived in
Blackpool she was once destined to meet
a man on a blind date but on his way to
meet her the potential suitor had a
motorcycle accident and broke both of
his legs a subsequent date walked into a
glass door breaking his nose and
incredibly Susan once had eight car
accidents in a single 50 mile journey so
if you look really is just a description
that we attached to ourselves so why do
some people like Susan genuinely lead on
luckier or luckier lives than others why
do some people always get lucky breaks
and find themselves in the right place
at the right time
whilst for some other people their life
seems like an endless crap
Wiseman suspected that perhaps look
could be somewhat self-induced people
who seek more sensations and experiences
are more likely to experience good look
to test this theory Weis been placed in
Arden a newspaper that took up half a
page and said in gigantic letters win
100 pound by telling the experimenter
you have seen this he then handed this
paper to a number of participants and
asked them simply to count the number of
pictures in the newspaper
most of the self-professed unlucky
participants failed to notice the huge
advertisements because they were so
focused on counting images those who
fought themselves lucky however usually
did notice the us and us for their 400
pound
it seems therefore that lucky people
have a natural instinct to make the most
of opportunities being lucky therefore
could be in no small part down to a
self-fulfilling prophecy phenomenon in
which some people have a proclivity to
take more risks seek more sensations and
therefore are statistically more likely
to have good fortune what people don't
realize however is that this is often
entirely of their own making who dares
wins as the timeless British special
forces slogan implies Wiseman postulates
that those born in colder months are
less lucky because they spend their life
taking fewer risks and seek fewer
sensations they are also more
introverted when compared to that
typically more extroverted some are born
folk this could be because the colder
weather during the first crucial months
of life permanently instills their
psyche with a natural aversion to
stepping outside of their comfort zone
and taking risks and so were less likely
to create their own good fortune but
what if your birth month could
scientifically predict your career if
this were true then it would mean that
couples would plan their child's
conception and thus their birth
depending and what they want them to be
dentist or a tax collector which
sadistic parent wants their child to be
a tax collector is beyond me
now this isn't as science fiction as it
sounds research conducted based on data
collected from the Office of National
Statistics census in the UK found that
there was a very real and observable
correlation between what month oppose on
is born in and their career but there
were also strong links to one's
intelligence and health issues January
babies are most likely to become debt
collectors or doctors February artist or
traffic warden March pilot or musician
April well this one is pretty damn awful
to be honest
April births were the most closely
associated with health issues a low IQ
and the disproportionate amount of
dictators including Hitler were born in
April May is far more optimistic May
babies are most likely to be sports
captain's or politicians June means a
chief executive of a Nobel Peace Prize
winner July is a bricklayer or train
driver August also bricklayers September
most likely to achieve academically
October babies have the longest lifespan
those born in October lived on average
seven months longer than those born in
March November
yeah it's about one again most likely to
be a serial killer or schizophrenic
December dentist or a member of the
clergy as unbelievable as all of this
seems these correlations are subtle yet
very real and scientists think that
there are logical explanations it could
all relate to the different climate
conditions and sun exposure during the
mother's pregnancy that consequently
affect the baby's development in the
womb for example it was generally found
that those born closer to summer are
more intelligent and less likely to have
health issues such as asthma
schizophrenia and autism because for
such babies
the
majority of their mother's later
pregnancy cycle will be spent in the
darker monks and there will be less
light when the baby is born this means
that both the mother and the baby will
absorb significantly less vitamin D
which is vital for a baby's healthy
development especially during these
crucial first months keep in mind that
the study was based on data from the UK
where the hottest months are between
June and August the study also found
links to a baby's birth month and how
tall they will grow as an adult and what
their body mass index will be
furthermore when you were born can
affect when you die sociologist David
Phillips from the University of
California San Diego has spent his
entire life researching why people die
when they do which must make him the
life and soul of parties Philips
analyzed three million Californians
death certificates and found that women
are most likely to die during the week
after their birth day than any other
time of the year conversely men are most
likely to die the week before their
birthday Philips suspects that this is
because women are usually more likely to
look forward to their birth day whereas
men tend to get stressed around their
birth day because they reflect on how
quickly their life is whisked by and how
little they think they have achieved
this buildup of cortisol caused by
stress causes the man's system to
malfunction and possibly expire more
quickly than it otherwise would have so
when your 80th birthday comes knocking
do try to keep calm because if you don't
it could be your last thanks for
watching I've recently launched my first
book which I'm crowdfunding sticker flag
in it a thousand years of bizarre
history from Britain and beyond the
crowdfunding campaign has reached one
hundred percent so it's definitely going
to be published thanks to everyone who
has pledged but there are still stretch
goals to reach so if you want a first
edition signed copy then head on over to
unbound
the links in a description watch the
launch video over there if you haven't
already and pledge today thank you